hey reject nation Greg Alva here John
we're gonna watch today Tekken 7 yeah
some trailer that has negan in it
apparently according to title I'm
excited to check this out by the way we
haven't done the Walking Dead Season 9
trailer reaction because I've only
watched the first episode of season 8
and I literally quit on the show because
I realized that manipulative this show
is yeah I'd get it first episodes are
always cool and it gets boring and
dragging I just suspected that would
happen but when it's on Netflix gonna
watch all season ages say yeah I'm just
gonna do it because Andrew link is last
season anyway though I play Tekken one
through five I've dominated on Tekken
Tag Tournament part 1 I mean I didn't
get part 2 who is your tag team would
you go to Hong Kong and lay along oh
good yeah my jam I was whoring and eddie
gordo eddie gordo button mash pieces hey
don't don't hate bro don't know will
hate anyone could be good with Eddie you
know what takes real skill maybe I was
just that good at kicking your buns but
for a moment you know seconds the only
game I get cocky that's the only one I'm
like I can dominate a page for the day
shout-out for the man from Japan who
lives in the Hawaii JT JT buddy
Minnewaska sweet talk to you I know
recently without going too much personal
stuff I know you had to go to the
hospital I'm glad to hear that you are
doing okay I just wanted to take time to
give you a sincere shout out and tell
you to get your [ __ ] together man now
what gives da-eun having these
conditions that you have that caused you
to go to Urgent Care what kind of BS is
that be a man put a bandaid on it walk
it off eat some Cheerios be happy be
healthy Hospital for stuff like that you
don't go to the hospital unless you're
dying or do you think you have an STD
two of which you did not think you did
have man up and I'll seriousness feel
better about yourself be beautiful oh
I'm a team
[Music]
the second project unreal engine light
physics
or conference was attacked
I think it was in the title I just
didn't read it it's like eSports of how
the Tekken characters just become buffer
[Music]
and every life playing with a hobby on
all the second game that's a Kirby I'll
tear you to pieces
there's me again
damn Nina's got a sexy ass outfit man no
this place is going to some kind of a
cop Suarez
oh damn dude
[Music]
not looking being to fight in this
outfit no what does that ever stop the
animation you can do [ __ ] like that now
actually anybody else want a piece
google it looks less and less like
Jackie Chan as time goes on yeah times
they are a-changin
yeah yo law you're getting your ass
handed to you right get that [ __ ] up
[Music]
let's leave they're getting so much more
cinematically there's no right where
right now break right there show us some
game plan she's always some game play
come on
[Music]
a little bit of a what a tease man how
dare they put that into what idol not
show us that he's in there yeah Kim it's
gonna just read the title of God I mean
it's still chilling when you're in it
you're like yeah I wonder if you do like
a really impressive KO or something if
you're gonna like bludgeon the eyeballs
out of somebody's head or something well
this seems to be taking a little bit
more inspiration now I mean I didn't
play the last Tekken game like I said I
only played one through five and I
played a tag tournament but it seems to
be taking a little bit of inspiration
from the recent edition of like Mortal
Kombat some like injustice to
inspiration in terms of when you're
actually fighting you get a little bit
more cinematic and you could whip out
like random crazy combos like an ax with
a rocket launcher yeah towards the end
to do like the final blows or whatever
combos are getting crazier and yeah yeah
it seems like it's shifting in and out
of more cinematic type of angles it
looks like a good blend of that yeah
look more dynamic than just going left
and right yeah I don't know if it'll be
distracting when I'm playing the game
though there's something to be more
aware of or mindful of when you're
hopping in and out of those camera
angles and whatever it looks cool this
is the same as good old Tekken man it's
good old Tech in action just more combos
more craziness to ensue aside from the
negan thing I mean this just made me
want to play Tekken yeah you know this
looks really fun I mean seconds my Jam's
one game I can get cocky in when I'm
bursting cuz I actually know how to do
combos and stuff in this game labor long
I'm just remembering what he was like in
Tekken 1 and 2 it looked like Jackie
Chan then part three he got his own look
and now he he looks younger than he's
ever did this like drunken master thing
about him now he's back to like young
cocky looking cop yeah he looks like an
alternate universe version of Jackie
Chan of Jackie Chan have been like born
in America in the 80s like that even
like that meta thing with him hidden
camera yeah it seems like Tekken's of
all them is something that's a lot more
aware of what it is now
a little more swagger maybe I don't know
yeah it's a little more stylish cool you
know and as opposed to as I love Tekken
growing up yeah it was so serious and I
like that epicness but now it seems to
have a much bigger humor about it which
it's always kind of had that humor I
mean in part three you got a play as
like an old doctor scientist guy yeah
was a little dinosaur gone was his name
something yeah yeah when you got like
the big puppet guy you got the robot
yeah a fantasy but now I love the trash
talk at the beginning of these games now
before they fight because it's so
horrible it's just like the worst trash
talking and now they seem to just be
having a lot more funny to go along with
it I feel like they're they're aware now
that they don't need to be quite as
gung-ho about like the plotline in this
this stinks it's like y'all here to kick
each other's asses and see who's better
at the game I mean Tekken was the was
the game though that I would love
looking into because you know that in
the early days of Tekken they didn't
have like a lot of you know actual
dialogue going on you'd have to look up
what the storylines are so you can
better understand and there was an
animated movie actually honored the
storylines pretty accurately which I
really like I don't really love that
movie but I liked it at least honored
the storylines yeah it's not like so
many video game movies don't even
acknowledge the source material yeah
that's gratifying I never saw the live
action movie but it's great yeah this is
a good old-fashioned second man the
gameplay looks great it's something that
I can't wait to pick up Tony Gill if
you're watching we're gonna battle each
other out I'm gonna destroy your
buttocks in front of everyone everyone
being my girlfriend and your girlfriend
and maybe if John is dick and then I'll
play whatever loses yeah and then you'll
hand the controller right back
thanks man hey I've beaten you in second
before I pissed you off once and then
you be and I take that as a victory and
I play Tekken I become Russell Crowe
from gladiator and from as long as
they're doing the whole like pop culture
tie-ins man did that very relevant at
Hunt in there too that would be fun
his introduction into the ring yeah
alright guys well are you excited for
negan to be joining there's gonna be a
lot of baseball action
I wonder if cuz over the lines from the
show obviously it just sounded like they
took dialogue from the show or if
they're gonna have Jeffrey Dean Morgan
actually do voice over work for this
which would be really sweet lord john
bailey and i wonder if or are for the
you know the japanese version if he
knows he'll speak japanese with a
southern accent anyway guys you excited
for this who do you think they should
add to tekken put it in the comments
below you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation hey click that
notification Belka subscribe button suck
and you can check us out patreon full
line TV show reactions weekly Q&A is a
music video coverage we'd love to have
you become a patron object today